what does it mean to be an international
bestseller for me like there's no direct
I don't think there's any specific
qualification but for me I didn't want
to use a term like that unless I could
back it up I hit the best seller lists
on Amazon you know for my category which
was you know various kinds of there's
various categories on Amazon so I tend
to show up in categories like spy
Thriller assassin Thrillers political
Thrillers those kinds of categories and
I hit number one more so Amazon will
award you a bestseller tag if you hit
number one and stay there for a certain
amount of time I don't know if anyone
knows how long it is maybe there's a set
amount of time I have a feeling it's
probably dependent on the market and how
many books Amazon is selling at the time
but just because you hit number one
doesn't mean you get that tag you have
to hit number one and stay there for a
certain amount of time and so when my
books had hit number one and gotten that
tag in multiple countries that was when
I just I was like well I guess I'm an
international best-selling author so
and so that was for red phoenix
uh no that was for
um let's see
Tokyo black hit the best sellers list in
Canada
and a cold kill I believe hit the best
seller list in America
another book called depth chart which is
when I co-wrote that also hit the best
seller list in America and the uh the
boxed set of the first three books that
also uh got the when I say hit the best
seller list I mean it earned the Amazon
bestseller tag
so and so America Australia
you are Canada America Australia those
are the three territories where I I got
it so
what amount of time did that take to
happen
um it was over the course of years I
mean for sure it wasn't all at once
because those books were released at
different times
um
yeah I was kind of like I didn't really
think about it you know I I was super
stoked you know to get those bestseller
tags of course but at the end of the day
they don't mean as much you know I mean
they draw the reader's eye to the book
and of course they're indicative of
success but like I said for example red
phoenix which was by far my most
successful book did not earn you know
one of those tags it for whatever reason
like you know maybe it was number two in
its category I don't know but
um but that book was my most you know
financially successful and it didn't
earn it so I mean I I don't think
I wouldn't really like advise like
chasing things like that and I mean sure
they're nice when they happen and of
course they can be beneficial but I
don't think there's beneficial as people
think you know I've heard a lot of
interviews with uh
really successful self-published authors
like you know people that are making
like Millions at it and they've they've
kind of done uh analyzes over uh you
know how much of a sales bump do you get
when you're the New York Times
bestseller versus you know just being a
successful book and it's not as much as
you would think you know so I certainly
wouldn't let that hold you back you know
being afraid oh I'm not going to hit the
best seller list
I don't think it's as important as
people believe it is maybe recommended
in search more yeah it's possible like I
said I'm sure it helps a little but
if you don't hit it that does not mean
your book is a failure sure
do you ever go on Goodreads and and as
an author and I see sometimes authors
interacting and do you ever I do I not
as much as I used to mostly because I
find my readers don't use it as much
um
yeah I mean I
it's it's there and I do use it and some
I think certain communities are much
more active like I definitely think the
romance Community is Super Active on
there so you kind of got to go where
your readers are
I do have my own Facebook group so I
communicate with readers there
um you know there's all different
Avenues
your goal with Tokyo black was to make
millions and retire on a beach somewhere
I don't know isn't that what every
writer tells himself right no I maybe I
said that in interviews but my goal was
definitely to
finish it you know finish a book and
then when I published it I just wanted
people to enjoy it you know I really
wanted people like I said I wanted
people to feel like they had gone to
Japan you know or feel like they'd
experienced that and to you know be
excited and it's an action book so of
course I wanted people to get pumped and
I remember
I remember when the reviews for Tokyo
black started coming in you know that
was really nerve-wracking actually and
this is sort of part of the process so
with with reviews on Amazon
you sort of need to kind of jump start
it a little bit because you know
probably only about one percent of
people that read your book are going to
leave a review you know that it's not a
high percentage of people that go back
and do that so what you do is you uh you
build up a review team of advanced
readers where you're like okay you know
people who have joined your list like I
said you build that mailing list and
then you say hey
um you know my book is going to launch
on this day here's an advanced copy can
you please leave your honest review
whether you like it whether you don't
like it whatever you think you know just
leave it on Amazon you know on this day
you know
um so you kind of know when the reviews
are going to start to come in because
you've told everybody and I remember I
was I hadn't you know I hadn't gone
through that because with Devil's Due
that I there was no review team you know
like that was the first thing I launched
I didn't have a mailing list or anything
I was building it so I and I hadn't
really thought about that then when I
launched Tokyo black and the launch day
came I was like oh my God like I'm gonna
get reviews you know like what if people
don't like it you know and I remember
the reading the reviews that they were
coming in
and they were so like just exactly what
I had hoped they would be and I don't
just mean good reviews I mean that
people commented specifically about the
setting and about feeling like they had
taken a trip to Japan
um and I remember this one woman wrote
you know I've traveled all over the
world but I've never been to Japan and
now that I've read this book I'm
planning my next trip there oh and that
meant a lot to me you know because I had
really loved Japan and I really wanted
to communicate that to people and I
remember I was in the office we were in
a different place than we're living now
but I had this office and I'd like grab
my dog and I was like rolling around on
the floor because I was so happy with
that one review like just because it was
you know it was exactly what I had hoped
people would the way I hoped they would
respond right that's great you had
connected the reader yeah yeah
have you had any meetings with Hollywood
producers on turning the book into a
film television show I have um you know
there are
at multiple points in time uh producers
have contacted me
um you know some of those options fell
through but there is a team of producers
now that I'm working with
um that are you know they've
commissioned a pilot script I I chose
not to write it they asked if I wanted
to but I
felt like I was too close you know to
the material as a book so I thought it
would be better to get someone else's
take on it
um
and we'll see I mean it's yeah it's in
progress so to be continued okay yeah I
don't know how much you can actually
talk about it but I mean I can talk
about it but it's uh I don't because I
didn't right I don't know a ton about
what's involved with it but I mean I
know that
um you know they're talking to some
they're exploring both movie and TV
series they're talking to some
showrunners that have you know pretty
impressive credits but I also know that
uh that's a long road you know I mean I
I there are best-selling New York Times
authors that have not yet had their you
know had their books option that have
not yet been turned into Series so I
mean I try not to get too involved in
that I don't want to like hold out on
that you know I focus more on the books
and the things I am more directly
involved in but yeah absolutely there's
a lot of progress being made and I'm
pretty excited to see where it turns up
was that a difficult decision to make to
say I don't want to do the screenplay no
it wasn't hard at all I I you know it's
funny
um the producer was really surprised but
I just felt like
I mean you know I've spent years writing
those books you know and so
and I and I know as a screenwriter I
know that to adapt a book you have to be
able to diverge from it where necessary
and I think it would have just been so
hard for me to see it in a different way
you know and I'm so
involved I mean there's you know there's
not a day that goes by where I'm not
thinking about Kane and his world and
the next book you know next story
um even even in between books you know
what I'm playing in the next one I just
thought it would I wouldn't be able to
to
give myself the flexibility you know
that you need to do a good adaptation
now maybe you know down the road I'll
change my mind and step in or something
but I thought it would I thought it
would was their best bet to like start
with a fresh writer did you ever get to
meet the writer yeah I did oh you did
okay yeah would you have lunch with them
and kind of like talk about the essence
of Kane and oh okay yeah and he did a
great uh pilot script for uh uh he was
working on the TV show side of it and he
did a pilot script and it's I've read it
it's good wow I'm excited how was that
to have someone else adapt your work
it's interesting it's really fascinating
you know the the ways that it's similar
in the ways that it's different
um
and uh you know I was sort of hesitant I
didn't want to you know I was like well
do you really want me to give notes and
they're like yeah yeah and I was like
okay well I don't think Kane would do
this you know or you know I like this a
lot but I would tweak it this way you
know I they're not obligated to follow
my notes it's just you
know but I I will say that you know
through again like I mentioned you never
know where these different projects are
going to take you because through
meeting these producers and through uh
you know meeting manager I signed a
manager based on these people that I was
working with and in one of the
conversations about Kane uh the producer
who was talking to the manager the
producer is a friend of mine he said oh
you know and Andrew also has this really
cool horror script and the manager was
like oh I think I could sell that and it
and it led to a whole different you know
Avenue and that script is now optioned
and set up and it looks like it's going
to happen so I mean again you just you
never know like what your route is going
to be and that's why I think
it's good to explore all different you
know kinds of writing and have lots of
different irons in the fire and don't be
afraid if something if one thing isn't
working or it's not advancing move over
to something else or try try your hand
at this or you know push this for a
little while and see where it gets you
because you just never know right so
this this DIY route can actually
eventually lead to a quote-unquote
gatekeeper yeah exactly I never thought
of it that way but
it is a good way to look at it you know
until you get your material out there
you can't do anything with it you know I
mean you need to show that audiences
respond to your work and you need to see
for yourself how audiences respond to
you and then once you do who knows where
that'll take you or who might get
interested or what you know what
opportunities that might lead to